est-ce que vous rabattez le couvercle
aventurer la chasse d'eau vous devriez
je vais vous montrer ce qui se passe
quand on tire la chasse d'eau des
chercheurs de l'Université du Colorado
ont étudié la question de près les
chercheurs en chasse d'eau pour faire ça
ils ont éteint la lumière des toilettes
ils ont mis des lasers verts dans toute
la pièce ils ont tiré la chasse des
centaines de milliers de gouttelettes ce
sont répandus dans la pièce c'est joli
ces petits trucs brillants envers fluo
mais en réalité c'est un véritable
aérosol d'eau au caca projeté à une
hauteur de plus d'un mètre 50 ce qui
veut dire que dans ces petites gouttes
pailletées il y a des germes
des bactéries fécales des bactéries
véganes qui sont réputées pour
transmettre des maladies au minimum pas
très agréable genre la gastro et au pire
potentiellement mortelle genre des
intoxications bien vénère toujours
rabattre le couvercle avant de tirer la
chasse d'eau après vous faites comme
vous voulez moi je
toujours se laver les mains aussi